皆さんこんにちはバーン社団法人落語協会の
三遊亭圓右大手ございます
ひさしにより若いですよ
a 今ですね酪農家のプロの数がだいたい東京と大阪と併せまして
830人くらい
色だという
そんなにいらないそうですね
62れ朝リーグでしょう
多すぎると言ったらお前もいらんって言われるんですよ
岩内もが良かった
東京に2つ協会があり
先日亡くなりました桂歌丸さんは私と別の協会の会長さんをされております
私はもう一つの教会商店で言いますと
林家きくを主張ですね
東さんが私と同じ方の境界ということになり
大勢ラコンかおりますけれども猿翁なんでこんな名前技な名前をつけたのは
落語の歴史上私が初めてでございます
一番偉そうな名前と言われてい
英語でキングオブはサークルた頃集
名古屋大学出てるから英語ぐらい使うんだよ
52年に
平野理学部地球科学教室というところを卒業させていただき
これからすぐには今回になったわけですが
楽満の歴史も江戸時代から二百数十年でしょ
あるんですがまぁ最初はもう
学歴なんてことは関係ない社会で
1日でも早く入った方がいいとしも関係なく上の先輩になると言う
あて車
ですから私の主将は方向卒業ぐらいでしたが
その上の詠唱しようというのは学校に5日間くらい入ったかな
ダーク歴然
こういう正解です
で私の十数年ぐらい前から大学を卒業した先輩が
この職業に入ってくるようになります
ところがですね国立大学の中隊の方はいらしたらしいんですが
国立を卒業して楽他になったというのは私が歴史上初めてということで
多分感じ
他に自慢することないんですよ
しかも理科系とやっぱり後楽4厚どっちかっていうと文系ですよね
これが結びつかんですからもうねなった当時は
会う人ごとになんで名前だけで0
決まったようなことを聞かれましたねほどテープレコーダーに答え吹き込んできかして
やりたいかなぁ
んなでことばっかり聞かれました
初めから大公開なろうと思ったわけではもちろんありませんで私はあの
両親が学校の先生美してい
花小学校スチガ高校の凶
あ今先生ってな実は家へ帰ってきてからもね本当に忙しく色んな
月様をやってるんですよそれ見て育ちましたので先生だけではあるまいと思ってい
育ちました
もしがこの先生になるなら大学の先生って相当自由でなくそうじゃないかな
そういうことを漠然と思っていました
私初めからですねど字を切って学校行くのもあまり得意じゃないですから
決まった時間に会社へ出勤して上司から嫌な仕事を押し付けられてそういうのだけは
絶対やだなと
なるべく自分の思うようなことをして一生過ごしたい
まあ移し自由にしたいというのが本来私の生き方に対する希望みたいなもんだったん
ですね
ところが高校の頃
まあ名前大理学部トレード目指したんですなぁ
とりあえず物理が何かをやって世の中の為にもなるし自分も真面目に生きて
大学の先生になれたらいいなというようなそういう
ハイとはしてないけどもなんとなくそっちの方へ行きたいなというその夢だけで
どちらかと言うと受験のための10件
0アンバーに合格できたんですよさあ一年生の春ですよ
いきなり事件
最初の物理の授業
トロ大教授と言いましてねノーベル賞に近かった偉い先生なんですな
最初の物理の授業で先生が出てきてね
我々学生に何と言ったと思いますさあこれから事業をやりますが何語でやりますかと
いう
日本語に決まってるじゃないですか我々日本人なんだから
ただね日本も英語ドイツもロシアもどれでもいいさ
すごいですねそれぐらいでないとね
物理の先生なんか会えないわけですよ
それだけで済むやいいけど許せないのは友達の学生です
英語といった時に一番拍手が大
従兄弟きちゃったなあと思いましたよね
ほほう年公開の真っ最中
ゴールドメンバーさんという人が公開の真っ最中ん
でもしょーもな英語で授業を始まっちゃったんですよ
物理がろくにわから英語もろくにわから
試験問題は映画で帰ったん
指がわからないます
またしょうもねえから白紙で出すのもあれなんでだるまさんの縁を書いて出しました
手も足もでバスケっぷり
こういうシャレなんですけど
をしたら値段と10人ぐらいはちゃんと答え書いてる人がいるんですよ
ああこれはねとても目指すところを間違えたなとそういう本当に移りのできる優秀な人
がいっぱいいるんだから
これはで大学院博士になるのを目指しのはとてもこの人たちに勝つだけで
影響する気は私にはないなと言うんで早かったですね
1年生の夏ごろにもう理科系のシート諦めたんです
ソーラでね周りにもうちに仕事もありませんし
漠然と大学の先生にでもなったら嬉しいなそれだけで大学きちゃったんで
私は大学卒業したら何をやったらいいだろうて途方に暮れる状態でした
そこで残ったのは
やっぱり自分は何のために生きてるんだろうとか自分の人生楽しく
うんあの自分の思うように生きるにはさっき一定に自由ということが基本にありますの
でできれば自分の好きなこと守備が何かをお仕事にして
まあ守備だったらばねあの途中でつらいことがあっても頑張れるんじゃないかなという
ことを思ってます
私もともと部活人減でして高校の時に部活2弦実は名古屋残薬でもラフの研究部と言え
ないでしょうけど少林寺拳法
事件前強そうに見えないん
強いチョコじゃない
それのどっちかを選ぼうかなということだけでまぁ痩せてますからね
勝利でも売りだなということで楽号の方を選びました
で中退してすぐにでも楽を行こうと思ったんですがやっぱり親が反対しました冗談じゃ
ない
中台は許さないよとにかくね並になどにしても卒業してからもしなさい
ねいくら自分が自由に行きたいとか言っても親の意見までは星できませんのでね
とりあえずま卒業が者しますかん
卒業の後は自由にさせて下さいねみたいなことを親に言ってとりあえず3年生から学科
に分かれます
私ねまあ物理はダメなんで地球科学というところがあります
選考が致死が地球の歴史の地碑があるんですね
たちが入ったら過失致死だと言われたんですけれどもね
それでもあろう
そこ行ってまた驚いたのはね同級生机を提供しつ並べている男が稼ぎマニアという
今でお宅ですね
誰も机の上には三葉虫だとか化石がずらっと並んで
パラ英語とがドイツ語の減少がずらっとか席のほうがあって彼らその化石を見て1時間
でも2時間でもよだれを垂らさんばかりに炒めた2体に接してい
定食でしょ
私の机違いますよ平凡パンチプレイボーイ
三遊亭圓生選手頃性分がありません
彼は直角というあだ名がありん
猫いうわけかと言いますとねものすごく真面目で律儀なうことで
例えば56人で食事に行くとしますよねディメートルぐらいの細い路地から左へ曲がる
とすると腰そこに信号があっても我々のほとんどは国の規則には違反してるのわかって
ますけど少しずつ左いってひょっとが上がるで
所はその男は絶対直角にしか上がらない
どんな狭い路地でも信号があれば必ず一人でそこで待ってて
我々が部校でこうやって待ってるのに全く平気で悠々とかを渡ってくる
親しい友達はゼロでしたね
友達は稼ぎだけ
その彼が何とおっしゃったかと言いますとね俺は酒たばこ麻雀女に興味はないと言う
俺が好きなのは稼ぎだけだ
それぞれが結婚したから怒れるじゃありません
僕言ってやりまして御ないラーメンってそう言って大家族計画は別って勝手なこと言っ
てましたよ
今一般舐め化石の教授になっています
転職ですねやっぱりそういうの見るとますますねやっぱりそういう仕事はそういう形に
おまかせをして私は私らしく生きるしかないなということですよ
姉もドクターだしとこーこーでぃ年生の時に私違うクラブをやってたので友達が年
ちょっと今落語研究会人数が足りないから
日々もやらないというで今から思うと悪魔のささやきでした
何の気なしにねらこのクラブ入っちゃったん
それはですねそれまでの自分があっ
件 vivayou とおかしいかもしれませんが人前でこんな話ができるような
そんな明るい感じじゃなかっ
どっちかというとまあクラスペ
例えば昼休みに誰もそばに寄ってこないようなそういうタイプの人間だー
それは私が自分で陸自たらご縁がありまして
もっと明るくなって友達に慕われるような人間になりたいなという気持ちがあった
その代わりがこう研究会入ったら成績はガタ落ちになりました
でねまた私何か好きなことあると述べる昆布等でして音樂も始めたらねこれはやっぱり
勉強や面白いですよ
これで覚えた小話なんか友達が目昼間
いる休みになるぶーデッキはも種類のやれよえっ
うってくる友達に受けようとだった俺小話
あるじゃない
以下いっ
おばあさんやー
ボケ防止の方を買ってきたぞおじいさん
機能を買ってきたでしょ行くか
簡単でしょ
これだけで友達の評価がまるで変わるんですよ
やっぱり成績落ちたけどラフをやってよかったなぁ
こういう短いからもうじゃなくて心立と言いまして
これはもうね覚えるの簡単です
あのだーでというのが口癖のばあちゃんが九官鳥を買っております
エルスにチームやさんが周辺に行きましてねこんにちはー
新分野ですが九官鳥まだあれ
楽しん分野でする誰
新聞や下スマ誰新聞会です
誰渋谷
アーサーと言うんだよ新聞屋さんあんまり長くやってたんでそこに倒れていっ
そこおばあちゃんは各界ときては上がるか倒れてるわね誰っつったら9課長が新聞や
です
お分かりにならない方ちょっと登っていただい
技術館て来話があります
美術館これはねーまあ面白い話なんですよ
係の方あの子の絵はルノワールフェスだね
様申し訳ございませんこれでいてますけども
フェルメールなんでございますよ紅蒼
同じ処方で似てるわねああこれはマネーでしょ
それもねでございます
明日違うじゃないんだからあこれ私にもわかるわ
ピカソね言えそこは釜にでございますよ
洗えない方も指変わってるね
ポポロフィールドがでと話しと言いまして
いきなり15分耳痛30分からもやる前に声の覚えてま訓練しましょうみたいなこと
プロになっても最初一字姓に襲われとか短いのからやるわけで動画何も使わなくてね
センソて眠いこれだけでも買い
今日は残念ながら講座もありませんのでねこれ持ってきただけで寝ないと思われると
困るからしてみろ化してるだけな気
ふぇみんなーの自分の名前向かいたーーー扇子と手ぬぐいのね
プロア必ずます
いたもっ
であのなんと彼ら効果と黒になればしっ
誰担はひじんですけどもやっぱりですね
封建社会で厳しいでもうねぇやっぱり一生の言うことは絶対です
白いものも黒でその間は自由どころじゃないですね
自由は0しかし家5年その前座時代をくぐり抜ければあとはら効果というのはわりと
自由だというのはわかってましたら
それから自分で親を説得して無理やりなった職業ですから多少と辛いことがあっても
それはもう自分から望んだことですから挫折する理由
いません
またね落語のショー等こういうことが新別なんですよ
しゃべることでレイヤーの生計立ててるぐらいでしたらみんな口が上手いでしょ
オスぼさんみたいに女ひっぱたかれるとかそういう体罰はありません
また来たくても非常に体力がありません
これはないんですけど口でもっていじめらー
これがなかなかねえ大変ですよ
位とダメです
a お前ちょっと暗すぎるからなラコがやめろと言うんで破門になっちゃった友達がい
ます
暗くていいのはってて葬儀社へ就職したらそこでも暗すぎるって時になったらそういう
子にはやたらと向かないんです
私なんかだよなんにも悪いことしないのに
大学出てるというだけで大何か嫌われましたいやが奴だな
んねぇ生意気です目ので大客殿かで言って楽やってやる
え番協悪いことしてない
東映でもうねをボロクソに悪く言われたね
を今もうね東大2京大卒
すごいでしょ日本の国立大学ほぼ全滅状態ですよ
あのウィンナーラグーンか言いますよだから後楽を
カポネなダークスーツグラージオドロスやりかの大学でたそう言うともう
ら効果やってるのもいますから今そんなに不思議で追われなくなりましたけど
ああ私が入った頃はネカフェアタリがきちゃったというそういう状況です
でも生姜またねーたまたま厳しい師匠のところ入っちゃったもんですから
もうね5年間といってもこれこそ市二ツ星
練習って言葉がありますけど1日が先日ぐらいの中でね
でも生姜で子を育てようという気持ちの温か衣装だったら良かったんだけどちょっとで
もミスがあったらすぐに破門してやろうというような
と思うよね厳しい症だから
私毎日年いつクビになるかと言うんで
は事なのつまり搬入しなくちゃいけないわけで
は大変でしたねそれでも実は4会派本になっています
ヨドバのときはホントで追い出されちゃったんですけども
最初の3回は名人の6代目炎症という方が助けてくれます
おそらく園消臭自分ががプレビ0なって
べしに最高額で気が入ると気持ち良かったんですよねそれでアイクあた捨てろという
ことになって
3ドア
非常に助けてもらう次にハ本あった時はご財務のご参照という人間国宝なった市長が私
のことを愛すは教会に置いとけと左手
助けてくれます
この賞は自分の弟子の名前を全部覚えられなかったと優勝なんですがなぜか私のこと
だけはよく覚えててくれますこれは今度は少林寺拳法役に立ちましてね
お産しを検討7が私少林寺拳法7か
白道つじゃないということで沸かせたことだけはよく覚えてて
くれてあいつは置いとけと言う音樂もと全然関係ないことが私にとっては脚本家人生約
いただき
ボーイマッシュおりません完全365日自由ですっ
hey あそれでもねあのただ自由といっても
ん
やっぱり学校の方にくーねるところにすむところが大事だありますけども
衣装を抱いてないところはダメなんで私もね
まだまだ
裕福とは言えませんしせっかくら豪華にも慣れたんで
自由はある程度勝ち得たんですけれどもただ区のでねこれから学校となる
数百あるんですがみんな持ちがいいと思っていると大間違いで
けっこうよくないのもあるってそういう子値を修正していくような仕事を
これから私どんどんやっていきたいと思って
ますみなさんの影響はまああんまり時間がないのでこの辺で話終わりになっちゃうん
ですけれど今の自分にどのぐらい満足されているかということです
やりたくもない仕事をやるだけやって可能でもあたってこれが一番つまらないと思うん
ですよね
だから自分が自由私は自由を得るために一生懸命自分
あるいは周りと戦ってここまでやってきてある程度は自由というものを選んだつもりで
おります皆さんも何かにセットしなきゃいけないことがあるかもしれませんけれども
できるだけ自分の自由自分の本当のものというのを見つけていただいて今よりも楽しく
て有意義な人生にしようじゃありません
私はそれを
になっております
今日は夫シャベルたいんですがフォアとの用意がよろしいようでございますどうも
ありがとうございましたます